Let's wrap up this lesson.
We've talked about three key ways
to compute the value of a company.
Intrinsic value,
which is based on future dividends.
In other words, companies pay a certain
amount to their investors every year,
based on how many shares they own.
And this is the value of all future
dividends going into the future.
Book value, which is the value of the
company if we split it up into pieces
and sold those individual pieces.
And finally market
capitalization which is
simply the value that the market
is placing on the company.
So, many stock trading strategies
look for deviations between say,
intrinsic value and market cap if
intrinsic value drops significantly and
the stock price say is high, it may
be worthwhile to short that stock.
Or if say dividends are going up and
the market capitalization is low it
might be an opportunity
to buy the stock.
And similarly book value
provides a sort of lowest
price, when stock price begins
to approach book value, you
can pretty much assume that the price
is not going to go below book value.
Or not much below it,
because if it does,
a predatory buyer would buy the whole
company, and break it up for parts.
Anyhow, that's company valuation.
And I look forward to seeing
you at the next lesson.
Bye bye.